qu'est ce que t'es moche on
ces nus en fait deux
franck dally vous a déjà dit ça à moi
mais ce n'était pas n'importe qui et oui
le problème c'était latent comme vous
l'aurez compris j'ai un gros problème
avec l'estiment que j'ai de moi même qui
doit être sûre d échelle de 0 à 10 à 1
peut-être même moi j'ai un bon sens de
l'humour c'est déjà ça farfan rigole
toute façon j'ai toujours fait des
blagues pourries je sais pas pourquoi je
mentais qd il ya encore peu de temps
je pense que j'aurais eu du mal à dormir
après ça j'aurais peut-être même plus au
ray mais ce n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui du moins j'essaye je vous
dis j'essaye parce que c'est pas facile
de contrôler son cerveau d'ailleurs est
ce que c'est possible en fait
eh bien on sait que notre cerveau ne
contrôle mais alors tout contrôler notre
cerveau méditer là dessus
si toutefois il était possible de le
contrôler une des premières choses à
faire ce serait de comprendre d'où vient
le problème
et c'est pas évident quand on a 12 13
ans de comprendre ce que celle estime de
soi alors de là à comprendre ce qui se
passe dans notre cerveau si encore un
autre problème
alors pour ma part j'ai compris quelle
était l'origine du problème en partie et
c'est d'ailleurs très courant chez les
adolescents le mal que je vivais était
essentiellement due à la compétition
avec massa qui a six ans plus que moi
quand même
elle n'était absolument pas au courant
d'autres compétitions et je la vivais
exclusivement seul et il faut dire que
c'est difficile d'égaler les exploits de
quelqu'un qui en école d'art chi kung
nous rentre en cinquième ce qui fait que
je me sentais en permanence diminué et
j'ai une petite personne
pour ça et mes proches ne sachant pas
trop quoi faire ou décidé de me diriger
la psychologue pour enfants
alors au début j'étais réticent que j'ai
pas envie mais finalement je me suis dit
s'il ya bien quelqu'un qui va pouvoir
m'aider
et bien c'est une personne qui s'y
connaît alors j'y étais je me suis
confié et une fois que je l'avais fait
j'ai pris tellement peur que j'ai arrêté
d'aller voir alors très mauvaise idée à
savoir que joe une psychanalyse on
arrive avec une quantité moyenne de
problème on va amplifier l'impact de ces
problèmes en mettant un mot dessus et le
reste de la psychanalyse est censé nous
aider à résoudre par nous mêmes le
problème mais quand on s'arrête en cours
et ben c'est jamais très bons mais
j'étais confronté en fait à un dilemme
j'étais confronté entre le fait de
vouloir comprend le problème pour le
résoudre et le fait de faire souffrir
mes proches qui eux se sentait coupable
de ma situation
et moi je me sentais coupable qui
sentent coupables c'est pour ça que j'ai
tout arrêté
j'ai fait semblant semblant tout allait
bien
semblant que j'étais infaillible je me
suis créé une carapace et dans cette
carapace est bien le problème était
toujours là et pire encore le problème
s'amplifier sans que je ne puisse rien
faire
une des conséquences principales du
manque de confiance en soi
eh bien c'est la peur la peur de
décevoir
la peur de ne pas être à la hauteur la
peur d'être jugé aussi et toutes ses
peurs et bien vous m'empêchez d'avancé
quand j'avais 16 ans et demi j'ai
rencontré un garçon tout se passait bien
s'entendaient très bien et tous les feux
étaient au vert pour qu'on se mette
ensemble
de son côté il me faisait comprendre
tant bien que mal que je lui plaisais et
de mon côté
eh bien je passais mon temps à me dire
toute façon il voudra jamais que toi
c'est pas assez bien pour lui
c'est pas ben y pense et puis même si tu
te mets avec lui toute façon dans deux
semaines ce sera fini c'est pas la peine
alors au bout d'un moment j'ai passé ces
barrières de la peur et on a fini par se
battre ensemble
mais problème il était toujours là et je
continue à me dire toute façon il va
bientôt quitter il va te quitter c'est
sûr il va trouver mieux que toi c'est
normal quoi
c'est pas la peine d'espérer quelque
chose et cette peur que j'avais je me
creed m'empêchait d'avancer sereinement
dans cette relation
mais qu'est ce que c'est la peur au
final si on prend le larousse la
définition exacte appréhension une
crainte face à un danger qui poussent à
fuir ou nous pousse à éviter la
situation si on a nous fichent bien d'où
est-ce que ça provient toujours la même
chose de notre cerveau alors je suis
étudiante en master de neurosciences et
on sait qu'il existe une structure dans
le cerveau qui va être impliqué dans ces
phénomènes de peur cette structure est
bien celle amicale que l'on voit en
rouge ici sur cette image alors je vous
parle on structure mais c'est pas aussi
simple en fait il s'agit d'un circuit
qui intègre cette structure alors en
rajoute encore de la complexité
ce circuit est composé de deux voies
différentes
une voix courte et une voie longue alors
ce concept est pas forcément facile à
comprendre
donc je vais essayer de me l'expliquer
tel qu'on nous l'apprend durant nos
études est tel qu'il a été exposé par
joseph le doubs en 1994
alors prenons un marcheur qui serait en
pleine nature et qu'ils voient ce qui
s'apparente à un serpent par la voix
courte et bien le circuit va s'activer
et
des réponses physique vont se mettre à
place tels que la frayeur du recul un
sursaut et après une courte latence
seulement et bien la voile longue elle
va envoyer l'information perçu au cortex
visuel qui va ensuite être transmis au
cortex sémantique et le cortex
sémantique lui va analyser la
dangerosité de l'information perçu si il
s'agissait bien d'un serpent et bien
l'action annie d'alien elle est
maintenue et la réponse corporelle elle
va perdurer
fouillez loin si au contraire jeter sa
main un bâton
et bien non ces cas-là l'action
amygdalien nll effréné et les réponses
corporelle s'estompe
je veux dire par là c'est que c'est
compliqué de comprendre ces phénomènes
de peur est en fait là il s'agit d'une
peur physique tangible mais comment ça
se passe dans les cas de peur
psychologique quand on est incapables de
matérialiser ce qui se passe et bien
c'est le même circuit qui est impactée
et qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce qu'on peut arrêter ce phénomène
de peur bien non oui mais on pourrait il
nous suffirait d'enlever nos amis
d'aller je parle pas c'est de celle qui
a dans votre bouche et on ressentirait
plus la peur mais imaginez les dégâts et
la dent janvier dangerosité que cela
générerait si nous n'avions plus peur de
rien alors est ce que mon problème vient
de là est ce que j'ai les amygdales trop
active et bien c'est pas si simple que
ça malheureusement ou heureusement pour
moi d'ailleurs
en fait c'est toute notre cerveau qui va
être impliqué là dedans
si on reprend les bases on repart du
départ on a un cerveau qu'on peut
diviser en trois parties la première
partie que vous voyez à l'écran
et bien c'est le cerveau reptiles c'est
celui qui est le plus en profondeur et
qui va gérer nos fonctions vitales
ensuite plus au dessus on a le savoy
limbique celui qui va gérer nos émotions
nos comportements nos juges où il est
également le siège de la mémorisation et
on a en surface le néocortex qu'on peut
lui également divisé en deux parties
partie droite est partie gauche le
cerveau droit étant plutôt émotif
intuitif créatif alors que le cerveau
gauche lui est plutôt logique théorique
enclin à la description
alors je vais tenter de vous expliquer
comment ces trois partis fonctionnent
ensemble pour générer nos émotions alors
l'information va arriver au niveau du
cortex visuel et va ensuite être
transmise
non non mais finalement je vais pas vous
l'expliquer c'est un peu trop complexe
mais c'est pas que le schéma qui est
complexe c'est bien plus le mécanisme
sous-jacent en réalité en réalité même à
l'heure actuelle on ne sait pas vraiment
expliquer dans le détail ce qui va
générer nos peurs nos émotions
notre confiance est ce qui relie tout ça
ensemble
bon je ne dis pas que les scientifiques
ne savent rien du tout 1 rassurez vous
on s'est quand même des choses il ya
quelques temps et bien je regarder une
vidéo sur youtube et un youtuber assez
connue a dit eh bien on peut avoir des
centaines de commentaires positifs sous
une photo les simples qu'on va retenir
c'est les deux ou trois commentaires
négatifs de haters
c'est comme ça c'est plus fort que nous
et il croit pas si bien dire au final
parce qu'il a été démontré de manière
scientifique que les émotions négatives
elle avait un impact beaucoup plus fort
que les émotions positives
alors est-ce que c'est peine perdue est
ce que une fois que j'ai perdu la
confiance en moi je ne pourrai plus
jamais à retrouver
est ce que mon cerveau ne couperaient un
subir ça eh bien je ne peux pas me
débarrasser de ses émotions négatives
qui sont générés quand je manque de
confiance en moi mais par contre je
pense qu'elles sont générés pour une
raison donc ce serait complètement une
erreur de décès s'en débarrasser alors
plutôt que d'essayer de les faire
disparaître et par gc minimiser leur
impact
pour cela une première étape c'est
d'accepter
ok je manque cruellement confiance en
moi et ça m'empêche clairement d'avancé
c'est au final ce que j'avais commencé à
faire chez le psy à l'époque de mes 14
ans
mais je pense que j'avais ni la maturité
ni les connaissances pour passer à
l'étape 2 qui est de court-circuiter le
système habituel
alors je parle pas de match les doigts
dans la prise c'est un petit peu trop
radical par contre ce qu'il est possible
de faire c'est de prendre ses émotions
négatives avec un fort impact et d'y
associer toutes les émotions positives
qu'on peut associer afin de débloquer la
situation et de retrouver un minimum de
confiance en nous pour pouvoir avancer
et revenons sur ce garçon dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure il veut un petit
et il va le quitter
et bien dès que j'avais une crise de
confiance en moi et bien ce garçon mais
des ondes ont parlé ils faisaient pense
à toutes les choses positives que tu vis
à l'heure actuelle et je trouve ça
complètement stupide au départ je me
suis dit ça va pas m'aider mais en fait
il avait raison il avait totalement
raison et croyez le ou non mais
maintenant ça fait plus de sept ans
qu'on est ensemble on n'a toujours pas
quitté
de toute évidence et j'ai commencé à
avancer dans cette relation
quand j'ai compris que les pensées
positives pouvait être un outil
formidable
un autre exemple si après avoir échoué
durant ma paces je m'étais dit bon c'est
un échec mais qu'est ce que tu peux en
tirer
tu as quand même appris des choses tu
validé des modules c'est que t'es pas si
bête
puis tu te rendu compte que tu voulais
pas du tout faire ça ça c'est super tu
vas pouvoir vraiment faire ce que tu
veux moment plutôt que de me dire toute
façon tu es nulle part il doit jamais à
rien tu peux arrêter tes études là parce
que c'est même pas la peine de continuer
eh bien je pense que j'aurai vécu cet
événement non plus comme un échec mais
plutôt comme une étape vers la voie que
je devais vraiment suivre et j'ai fait
ça 1
avec chaque moment de ma vie où ce
manque de confiance en moi on m'a posé
problème et je n'ai fait jusqu'à ce que
ça en devient un automatisme et
maintenant
d'un vrai que je manque de confiance en
moi au lieu de me dire c'est pas la
peine ils fuient sort vite là je devrais
le faire et bien au lieu de me dire ça
je me pose je respire un peu et je me
dis quels sont les points positifs que
cet événement va pouvoir apporter
j'arrête de fuir et je décide
d'affronter alors il ya quelques temps
encore j'aurais été incapable de
présenter un talk eu de bambou et je me
serais dit de toute façon c'est pas la
peine tout le monde à se moquer de moi
et au final je me dis que je dois pas
être la seule dans cette situation
j'aurais dit la salle aviv ça y est je
pense que n'importe qui à un moment de
sa vie est confrontée à un manque de
confiance en soi et j'ai décidé de
partager mon expérience avec vous pour
peut-être aidé quelqu'un dans cette
salle qui est confronté à ça à ce moment
même c'est possible de moduler ses
émotions
c'est possible d'affronter ses peurs
mais surtout c'est possible de retrouver
notre confiance et maintenant que vous
êtes un peu plus au courant de ça
maintenant que vous voyez que j'ai
réussi à dompter mes peurs et à
maîtriser ma confiance je pense que vous
aussi vous pouvez pas revenir
et comme vous savez ce qui se passe là
dedans eh bien je pense que maintenant
vous pourrez trouvez vous aussi une
solution pour vous permettre de
transformer ce qui vous empêche
d'avancer en un véritable moteur qui
vous emmènera là où vous le souhaitez je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]